Apple September event is coming up
really soon and we're extremely excited
for the Apple watch series five so we
thought we'd come up with a list of the
top three unique help apps that you can
use right now on your Apple watch as
well as on future models the first tab
is called streaks and it basically helps
you create and track good habits as well
as break bad ones you can track up to 12
things a day from a huge list of tasks
that help you improve your health with
everything from taking a walk going to
the gym practicing an instrument reading
a book and even stuff like taking your
vitamins and flossing your teeth now I
don't know about you but I always tell
myself I'm gonna start doing something
like reading a book or taking a walk
every day but as soon as I miss one day
I tend to miss the next one and I simply
stop trying
which streaks you get customizable watch
faces and complications that remind you
of which tasks you've already completed
every time you look at your watch so
it's basically impossible to forget you
also get rich notification reminders and
it knows when you complete each workout
since it's automatically linked with the
help app and the best part is that it
keeps track of how many days in a row
you've completed each task so you can
see how long you've kept the streak
going which puts even more pressure on
you to get things done you can find
streaks on the App Store for a one-time
payment of $5 now the second app is
rocket body the sponsor for this video
and it's meant for people who take their
health and fitness seriously this app is
truly unique because it uses the Apple
watch series for zcg feature to measure
your heart's electrical signals and then
uses artificial intelligence to
determine your readiness for the next
workout and your level of recovery so it
gives you full high-quality control of
your body's condition throughout the day
professional athletes sometimes take
expensive electrocardiograms at the
doctor's office to make sure their
bodies are functioning properly during
their workout routines and raqqa body
does close to the same thing without
requiring a doctor's visit simply take a
30-second ECG test right on your Apple
watch before each workout and rocket
body will use artificial intelligence to
estimate your fitness condition create
smart workout plans help you choose the
right workout load and monitor your
recovery you can easily build a smart
workout plan that changes
and adapts to your specific ECG results
to help put you on a steady path towards
your fitness goals whether you want to
lose weight build muscle or just become
a little bit more mobile it even pulls
in your diet info from health kit so you
can easily manage all of it in one app
rocket body enables the beneficial
training and less people enjoy the
workout process and achieve their goals
you can try the rocket body app out for
free on the App Store with a 14-day
trial using the link below and once you
try it make sure to leave a review on
product ton and now for the third app we
have life some it's basically a diet app
that gives you things like diet plans
recipes and calorie tracking it starts
with the quiz that helps you personalize
your diet offering you various meal
plans like the new three-week weight
loss plan as well as recipes and
shopping lists that will help keep your
calories in check the calorie counter
has an extensive food database and it
even allows you to scan the barcode of
the food you're eating tracking the
exact amount of calories you're eating
without having to do your own
calculations and it gets even better
with an Apple watch you can track all of
your carbs fat protein and calories
right on your watch with completely
customizable complications but the best
part is that life some automatically
imports your body weight measurements
workouts and calorie burn data so you
not only know how much calories you're
eating but also the exact amount of
calories you're burning each day so you
can make sure you're burning enough
calories to meet your diet plan goals
you can get live some on the app store
for 750 a month or 45 dollars a year and
that's it for our list of the top three
unique health apps for the Apple watch
in 2019 shout out to rocket body for
sponsoring this video and if you enjoyed
it to have to like button and click the
circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]